flip or flop start oracle musa is  spending time with the kids following  his shocking separation from wife  Christina the HGTV stars recently opened  up to People magazine about the split  and what comes next we love what we do  we love each other quote neither of us  is ready to announce anything in terms  of another relationship we plan to  continue our professional life together  by being professional by doing our jobs  well our TV show is about our flipping  business and about our lives yes the  couple plans to continue working on the  HGTV series together they also have a  book out next year they say they decided  to split because it was in the best  interest of their children quote we want  the best for them and we're doing  everything we can to ensure that Tareq  and Christina share two kids  six-year-old daughter Taylor and  one-year-old son Brayden and for now  they are just separated not divorcing  [Music]